لم تكن هذه هي النهاية التي
وعدوا بها حتى لو بدأوا يشعرون
بمقاتلي داعش الأجانب الأبديين طالما أن
هذه الحانات في سوريا لم تعد تشكل
تهديدًا للعالم
الخارجي ولم يعد على دراية بما يحدث
في الخارج فيها هذا الرجل يقول اسمه  هي
ليليا سليماني ، وبصفته مواطنًا أمريكيًا مزدوجًا
، ليس لديه أي فكرة عن مقتل زعيم داعش
أبو بكر البغدادي
قبل 72 ساعة فقط عندما
زار مصورنا الحراس صراحةً ومنع
الزائرين من نشر الأخبار ، لذلك
يمكننا فقط أن نسأل ماذا لو كان هذا  المهارة هي
ذنبه لكثير من الأشخاص الذين
قُتلوا بالفعل ، لقد مات بالفعل ،
لا تسمع من Emmys ، أنت تعرف أنني
لا أعرف بالنسبة لي شخصيًا ، أشعر نوعًا ما
وكأنني تعرضت للخيانة قليلاً كما تعلمون
لذلك لا يوجد  لم يعد هناك دولة إسلامية
غير موجودة ، ها هي قصة شائعة
في البحر البرتقالي ، لقد كان مجرد
مهندس قلق على زوجته
وأطفاله الثلاثة والمخيمات القريبة
من مصيرهم غير مؤكد لدرجة
أنه يقول إن مواجهتنا العدالة ستكون
أفضل  إلى يوم آخر هنا ،
شكرًا لك غير آمن للغاية وهم تعلمون
أنني أريد العودة إلى الدول. شيء
واحد مؤكد لا أريد أن أكون هنا ،
لم يواجه أحد هنا محاكمة ولم يتم العثور عليه
مذنبًا ، والآن يتوق الكثيرون إلى الإجراءات القانونية الواجبة
أنكرت داعش الآخرين في اندفاعهم الهمجي من
أجل الحصول على الدم ،
وتعهدت داعش بتدمير رسالتي إلى
الشعب الأمريكي إلى دونالد ترامب ،
وأعني أن هناك مواطنين أمريكيين
لا ينبغي التخلي عنهم ، ويجب
إحضارهم إلى الفضاء وجهًا لوجه أمام
القانون  وإذا ارتكبوا أي جريمة أو
كما تعلمون ، يمكن أن يعاقبوا
لا يتركوا في مكان ما
مثل معسكر اعتقال الموت البطيء ، فقد
أضعف إيزيس بلا زعيم
هنا ولم يتوقف فجأة عن كونه تهديدًا ،
تخيل الغضب المحتضن في هذه
الزنازين بشكل كبير جدًا  يخشى الحراس مما قد
يحدث إذا علموا بخبر
وفاة قادتهم وغضب بلدانهم الأصلية
لا ترغب
في الغالب في العودة ، لكن ذلك يعيش بعد
وفاة البغدادي.  في هذه الخلايا نيك
باتون والش سي إن إن أربيل شمال العراق